well let's bring you more on that
breaking news now from the off gem chief
executive jonathan brealey who's told
the business energy and industrial
strategy committee that the regulator is
expecting an energy price cap increase
in october in the region of 2800 pounds
the current price cap
1971 pounds
conditions have worsened in the global
gas market with russia's invasion of
ukraine gas prices are higher and highly
volatile at times they've now reached
over 10 times their normal level
now i know this is a very distressing
time for customers but i do need to be
clear with this committee with customers
and with the government
about the likely price implications for
october
therefore later today i will be writing
to the chancellor to give him our latest
estimates of the price cap uplift
now this is uncertain we are only part
way through the price cap window but we
are expecting a price cap in october in
the region of two thousand eight hundred
pounds
let's bring our economics and data
editor ed conway ed this is a huge
amount of money that that families are
gonna have to pay for their energy isn't
it
i mean these are staggering the sums we
have never seen uh
a period like this with gas bills quite
as high
as they're heading gas and energy bills
and you know it's worth just kind of
taking a step back you know not long ago
you were talking about kind of levels
that were you know
pretty much
a third of what we are going to be
seeing later on uh this winter um and it
does just underline the scale of the the
impending cost of living crisis already
energy bills are at for many households
unbearable levels and the fact that
they're going to go up by another around
800 pounds uh in the autumn as far as
the current uh futures prices suggest
will be another blow it's worth just
underlining you know how how does this
work basically those energy bills or
indeed the price cap is set on the basis
of what's happening in wholesale gas
markets markets and if you look at
what's happening to futures prices which
is kind of what a lot of the energy
companies end up paying they are very
high and the upshot is you can see it
there if there were a 2800 pound price
cap as the head of uh off gem is saying
then if you're just looking at the share
of our energy bills it's the share of
our total spending
we'll just have a look that dotted line
goes up to the highest level kind of
around eight percent of total spending
uh across average households the highest
level we've ever seen before the dotted
line that that's further down is kind of
where we are at the moment so the
highest since the mid 1980s but we're
heading into unprecedented territory and
that's why there's potentially a lot of
uh extra pressure on the chancellor uh
to act 2 800 pounds not necessarily a
surprise i mean the bank of england has
been talking about that level uh in its
recent forecast but remember it was that
level that was going to prompt a
potential recession in the uk so we are
now heading for those kind of levels
that are
really damaging and really difficult for
many households and worth just noting as
well you know what i showed you a moment
ago was the average household if there
is such a thing if you're talking about
for many other households particularly
those on lower income brackets
it is a much greater proportion of their
spending just because energy costs make
up a greater proportion energy and food
another thing which is going up a lot in
price it's all of this underlining why
we are seeing more noises from the
chancellor about potentially doing more
in the way
of intervention later on this year
ed thanks very much